في هذا الفصل هنقدّم لك الإطار العام
للتفكير في بيئات الحوسبة
اللي ممكن تطبّقها على لابتوبك
أو توسّعها لتصل للحواسيب العملاقة
بنهاية الفصل ده
هتفهم المفهوم الأساسي لموارد الحاسوب
وإزاي بتترابط مع بعض
طيب إيه هي موارد الحاسوب ببساطة؟
هي المكوّنات اللي بتشكّل نظام الحاسوب
عندنا الـ CPU أو وحدة المعالجة المركزية
اللي بتنفّذ معظم التعليمات، وعندنا الذاكرة
أو الـ RAM اللي بتحتفظ مؤقتاً بالبيانات
وتعليمات البرامج
وعندنا كمان الـ GPU أو وحدات معالجة الرسوميات
اللي اتصمّمت في الأصل لعرض الرسوميات
بس ممكن كمان تُستخدم في مهام الحوسبة العامة
اللي محتاجة معالجة متوازية كتير
زي المحاكاة العلمية وتحليل البيانات والتعلم الآلي
هذه الموارد بتشتغل مع بعض عشان تنفّذ البرامج
وكل واحدة فيها بتُقاس بوحدة مختلفة
مثلاً وحدات الـ CPU بتُقاس بالأنوية
وسرعة الساعة، أما الذاكرة فبتُقاس بالبايت
جيجا ومega وتيرابايت
لكل مشكلة من مشاكلنا
هنحتاج مجموعة من الموارد
عشان ننفّذها
من الضروري نفكّر في الموارد المطلوبة لتنفيذها
بكفاءة، والمكان اللي بتُنفَّذ فيه مكوّنات البرنامج
وعرض نطاق البنية التحتية اللي بتربطها
بيلعبوا دور مهم جداً
في تحديد الأداء الكلي
مثلاً الـ GPU ممكن يكون أسرع في حساب أجزاء معينة
من برنامجنا، لكن لو تحميل البرنامج لذاكرة الـ GPU
بياخد وقت أطول مما نوفّره
ممكن يكون استخدام الـ CPU أسرع في الواقع
خلينا دلوقتي نتكلّم عن توسيع الموارد الكلاسيكية
عندنا نهجين: التوسيع الرأسي
والتوسيع الأفقي. التوسيع الرأسي بيعني زيادة
قوة مورد واحد
زي استخدام CPU أقوى أو ذاكرة أكبر
داخل نود فيزيائي واحد
حيث الـ node هو وحدة في cluster الحوسبة بتضمّ موارد متعددة
بداخلها. أما التوسيع الأفقي
فبيعني إضافة موارد أكتر
زي عدة CPUs أو GPUs
تشتغل مع بعض على نود واحد أو أكتر
الاتنين ليهم مزاياهم
وعيوبهم، والاختيار بيعتمد على حالة الاستخدام
والمتطلبات. خلينا نعرّف نوع جديد من الموارد:
الموارد الكمومية. الموارد الكمومية بتعالج المعلومات الكمومية
بوحدة معالجة كمومية أو QPU. الـ QPU
هو النظام الكامل المسؤول
عن استقبال مجموعة تعليمات كمومية قابلة للتنفيذ
أو circuit كمومي وإرجاع
إجابة دقيقة. ده معناه
إن الـ QPU بيضمّ شريحة كمومية أو أكتر
زي مثلاً IBM Quantum Heron
بالإضافة لمكوّنات إضافية متعددة
داخل ثلاجة التخفيف
اللي بتحيط بالشريحة الكمومية
زي مضخّمات الإشارة الكمومية والإلكترونيات الضابطة
والحاسوب الكلاسيكي المطلوب
لمهام زي حفظ التعليمات
والموجات في الذاكرة وتراكم النتائج
وفكّ تشفير تصحيح الأخطاء مستقبلاً
بشكل عام الموارد الكمومية بتُقاس
من حيث جودتها بمقياس EPLG، والـ fidelity
وعدد الـ qubits
والسرعة: عمليات circuit layer في الـ
ثانية أو CLOPS. النهارده هنتعامل مع الشريحة الكمومية
كوحدة قياس، مشابهة لطريقة تعامل أنظمة إدارة الموارد
مع الـ GPUs مش بعدد الأنوية
لكن كوحدة كاملة. طيب إيه رأيك في التوسيع؟
زي الموارد الكلاسيكية، توسيع الموارد الكمومية ممكن
هو كمان يتصنّف لرأسي
وأفقي. التوسيع الرأسي
هيكون بزيادة عدد الـ qubits في كل chiplet
أو في كل شريحة
أما التوسيع الأفقي فبيكون بربط الشرائح
بـ couplers أو بوصلات كلاسيكية
بعد ما اتعرّفنا على التعريفات دي
خلينا نتكلّم عن إدارة الموارد
إدارة الموارد في البنية التحتية للحوسبة بتشير
لعملية التخطيط
وتخصيص والتحكم في استخدام الموارد الحسابية
زي الـ CPU والذاكرة والتخزين
وعرض نطاق الشبكة عشان نضمن
الاستخدام الكفء والفعّال للموارد
تقدر تتخيّل إدارة الموارد
كلعبة تتريس متعددة الأبعاد، المكعّبات
هي متطلبات شغلتك
وكل بُعد هو وحدة مورد. المهمة الأساسية
هي تلاءم مكعّبات الشغل دي في مكعّب
يمثّل كل الموارد المتاحة. إدارة الموارد
مهمة صعبة جداً، ومراكز الحوسبة المختلفة بتطبّق
تكتيكات مختلفة لتهيئة بنيتها التحتية
بناءً على احتياجات المستخدمين بتاعتها
عشان نطبّق المفاهيم اللي اتعلّمناها للتوّ، هنستخدم
SLURM. SLURM هو برنامج مفتوح المصدر
لإدارة الموارد
لأغراض العرض التوضيحي
عندي إعداد محلي بثلاث nodes افتراضية
نقدر نجيب معلومات عن الحواسيب دي
عن طريق تشغيل أمر scontrol
عندنا partition اتنين أو مجموعات nodes
normal وquantum. الـ normal partition مكوّن من nodes
عندها وصول للموارد الكلاسيكية بس
والـ quantum partition عنده وصول للموارد الكمومية
خلينا أوّلاً ننفّذ المثال البسيط
"Hello World" الكلاسيكي مع SLURM
أوّل حاجة محتاجينها هو برنامج Hello World نفسه.
وده هو برنامجنا اللي بيطبع Hello
World.
دلوقتي محتاجين نقول لمدير الموارد
إيه الموارد اللي محتاجينها عشان ننفّذ البرنامج ده
زي ما اتكلّمنا، SLURM بيوفّر طريقة لتحديد
كل البيانات الوصفية للشغلة من خلال
سكريبت shell
فيه annotations خاصة بـ SLURM
هذه الـ annotations بتخلّيك تحدد متطلبات الموارد
ومعاملات الجدولة وأكتر من كده.
نقدر نراجع سكريبت التقديم
وهنا عندنا تحديد الـ partition
وكام node محتاجين وكام task لكل node هننفّذ
وكام CPU لكل task هنستخدم
وأي سكريبت عايزين نشغّله
وده هو برنامج Hello World بتاعنا.
عشان نقدّم شغلتنا للتنفيذ، محتاجين نشغّل
أمر واحد بس وهو sbatch
ونحدّد سكريبتنا كـ argument
نقدر نراجع قائمة انتظار التنفيذ
ونشوف إن برنامج Hello World بتاعنا شغّال
على الـ normal partition على الـ node c1
لمّا الشغلة تخلّص نقدر نشوف النتائج
من خلال ملف الإخراج.
وبكده خلّصنا.
بنهتم كمان باستخدام الموارد الكمومية
فخلينا ننشئ برنامج Hello Qiskit بسيط.
ده هو برنامج Qiskit بتاعنا اللي فيه كل
الخطوات الضرورية لإنشاء الـ circuit
وتحسينه وتنفيذه ومعالجة النتائج.
وهنا كل مفاهيم البرمجة اللي اتكلّمنا عنها:
الـ quantum circuit والـ transpiler
وـ primitives بتاعت Qiskit
دلوقتي محتاجين ننشئ سكريبت التقديم
زي ما اتعلّمنا، لكن هنا بنحدّد
متطلبات الموارد الكمومية
بما إننا حدّدنا الموارد
والـ partition في الـ cluster
وبكده الموارد الكمومية المتاحة
الـ Qiskit primitives هتستخدمها
عشان تنفّذ الحسابات الكمومية.
دلوقتي محتاجين نشغّل برنامجنا.
ولمّا الشغلة تخلّص نقدر نشوف النتائج.
وده هو قيمة التوقع بتاعتنا.
وبكده نكون خلّصنا موضوع إدارة الموارد
في القسم الجاي هنتكلّم
عن نماذج البرمجة